according to various Hollywood media
reports talks are currently being held
about an HBO series based on the seven
Harry Potter books the idea is to
produce a separate season for each of
the books this would make it much easier
to cover more of the details of the
original books which have only been
marginally touched upon in the previous
films or not at all this would mean that
seven seasons of the world famous Harry
Potter Saga would be planned from the
outset this is naturally also associated
with certain risks especially if the
series is not as well received as
anticipated actually the idea has been
circulating behind the scenes for
several years but it is said to have
been put on the back burner for a while
after the merging of Warner Brothers and
Discovery now that the deal has been
finalized last year however production
seems to be picking up pace once again
CEO David saslav has already announced
that he intends to make some Harry
Potter projects a top priority in the
future Creator JK Rowling is also
expected to play an important role in
the new projects and act as a producer